[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert könig für den sport
guten amt wir haben heute diese themen
für sie
zurück zum bürger test ärzte fordern
wieder kostenlose corona schnelltests
für alle
wiener am pranger uiguren berichten in
deutschland über folter und gewalt in
umerziehungslager und
zwischen angst und faszination der
vulkanausbruch auf la palma wird zur
touristenattraktion
die korona lage verschärft sich
zunehmend in bayern gelten ab heute
strengere maßnahmen in sachsen ab morgen
auch die potenziellen regierungspartner
spd grüne und fdp planen offenbar neue
regeln die zahlen zeigen den ernst der
lage das robert koch institut meldet 23
1543 neuinfektionen wären binnen 24
stunden das sind
6656 mehr als vor einer woche die sieben
tage inzidenz steigt auf
191,5 in der diskussion sind auch
weitere beschränkungen für ungeimpfte
thomas konsum
rund geht's in hamburg bunt und wild
winterdom heißt der jahrmarkt reinkommen
aber nur geimpfte und genießen zwei
generell ein modell wir müssen
flächendeckend zweig erwägen
insbesondere in den außenbereichen wo
man sich schnell ansteigt restaurants
cafés überall dort wo größere
menschenmengen zusammenkommen
die überlegung weniger kontakte mehr
schutz jetzt wenn es richtung winter
geht
immer irgendeinen personenkreis
ausgeschlossen wird finde ich super weil
die ganzen ungeimpften jetzt vielleicht
einen denkanstoß kriegen sich impfen zu
lassen dieser denkanstoß auch ein ziel
dessen was seit vier wochen gilt grad
ist es nur in ausnahmen jeder solle
zahlen schließlich können sich auch
jeder impfen lassen tat aber nicht jeder
erst um zweit im dschungel gehen immer
weiter zurück im raten stagnieren die
vorstellung dass man durch das
kostenpflichtige den tests impfwillige
motivieren könnte sich zu impfen hat
sich offensichtlich nicht erfüllt
insofern würden wir zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt dringend raten die tests
wieder kostenfrei zu stellen auch für
mehr kontrolle und übersicht bei denen
davon eilenden zahlen also kostenlose
tests zweig von beidem etwas das ist
eine weitere idee ich würde nicht nur
eine 2d sondern eine 2 gelungen
vorschlagen bei der gamestar und
genesene zusätzlich getestet werden und
zwar kostenlos um eben das risiko zu
minimieren dass es doch zu aus geschehen
kommt wie weiter durch die pandemie der
winterdom er selbst ist eine art
experiment befürworter von 2g hoffen ein
erfolgreiches
bei unseren nachbarn in österreich liegt
die inzidenz bei etwa 600 ball dort gilt
ab morgen landesweit die 2g regel in
lokalen hotels oder auch beim friseur
vor den impfzentren bildeten sich am
wochenende lange schlangen viele
ungeimpfte wollen jetzt doch noch
schnell ihren tiefs rechtzeitig vor der
einführung der neuen beschränkungen
einen tag nach der messerattacke in
einem ic wurde jetzt entschieden der
täter bleibt in der psychiatrie er soll
unter wahnhaften vorstellungen leiden
tatort war ein zug unterwegs von
regensburg nach nürnberg dort hatte der
27 jährige syrer mit einem klappmesser
auf andere passagiere eingestochen der
verletzte vier männer drei davon schwer
die flutkatastrophe im juli hat rekord
schäden angerichtet insgesamt rechnet
die bundesregierung mit
29,2 milliarden euro so steht's in einem
antrag auf eu finanzhilfen demnach
entfallen mehr als die hälfte der
schäden auf rheinland pfalz weitere 40
prozent kamen in nordrhein westfalen
zusammen der rest in bayern und sachsen
jetzt zu einem volk dessen schicksal nur
selten in die öffentlichkeit rückt den
uiguren
1955 hat sich china ihre heimat die
heutige provinz xinjiang als autonome
region einverleibt seitdem versucht die
rund zehn millionen muslimischen uiguren
zur chinesin umzuerziehen von folter
lagern ist die rede und von grausamen
methoden wie grausam davon berichten
jetzt zwei frauen jutta sonne weiter
zugetroffen
gewalt erniedrigung und folter davon
können kelvin uhr & kohlbacher berichten
sie gehören zu den wenigen die aus
chinesischen gulag entkommen konnten wir
waren dreißig personen in einem raum
alle waren angekettet in der nacht
wurden wir gezwungen bei unter minus 30
grad draußen zu laufen man wollte uns
quälen und unsere widerstandskraft
brechen
manchmal verschwinden leute und kommen
nicht wieder frauen werden in gruppen
vergewaltigt und zur sterilisation
gezwungen auch ich wurde auf anordnung
der chinesischen behörden im mai 2009 10
zwangssterilisiert die un schätzt dass
rund eine million angehörige des
muslimischen turkvolkes der uiguren in
der region xinjiang im nordwesten chinas
in gefängnissen und arbeitslagern
willkürlich gefangen sind um sie mit
brutalen mitteln auf die linie der
kommunistischen partei zu zwingen peking
behauptet es ging um integration in
ausbildungszentren doch figuren würden
im baumwoll und textilsektor zu
zwangsarbeit verpflichtet mannen
menschenrechts organisationen in
deutschland frankreich und den
niederlanden wurden jetzt strafanträge
gestellt gegen große europäische
bekleidungsfirmen
zwangsarbeit ist nach dem völkerrecht
ein schweres verbrechen und unter
bestimmten umständen zum beispiel wenn
sie als massive systematische angriffe
auf die zivilbevölkerung durchgeführt
wird wie es heute in china der fall sein
könnte ist zwangsarbeit auch ein
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
kohlbacher und kelvin uhr sind morgen zu
gast im bayerischen landtag dann geht es
weiter mit vorträgen den elf deutschen
städten so hoffen sie auf mehr gehör für
die uiguren und ihren kampf um
menschenrechte
er macht angst fasziniert aber auch und
hat immer noch keinen namen seit sieben
wochen spuckt der vulkan in cumbria
gebirge auf la palma gewaltige
lavamassen aus tausende menschen hatte
bereits aus ihren häusern vertrieben und
zunächst auch die touristen verjagt doch
die kommen allmählich wieder wie
christel hass berichtet
es hört nicht auf das grollen das feuer
die lava eine tief schwarze rauchwolke
steht über dem vulkan asche die wie
regen vom himmel fällt sie dringt in die
augen und der starke wind wie sie in die
kleinste ritze im campingwagen statt im
eigenen heim leben sie auf diesem
parkplatz caro und ihr hund chiara sind
und seit dem beginn des vulkanausbruchs
dar ihr haus ist in der gefahrenzone es
steht noch aber die bananen von denen
sie lebten sind dahin
sie sind tot zum kurz vor dem ausbruch
gegner es sand und ein sehr heißer
winter alles verbrannt
ganz nah am vulkan sind spezialisten
unterwegs sie halten permanent die
lavaströme im auge keiner kann zur
stunde sagen wann das alles vorbei sein
wird
es ist die ungewissheit die allen an den
nerven zerrt die menschen hier wollen
endlich abschließen mit dem vulkan sie
wollen neu anfangen doch so lange der
vulkan weiter spuckt ist das unmöglich
dieser berg zieht aber auch viele
tagesbesucher an eine gezielte aktion
denn ein teil der einnahmen geht an die
betroffenen
ich hatte eigentlich zweifel aber jetzt
finde ich es wichtig gehört zu kommen
und auch ein bisschen geld auszugeben
50 lange tage ist das biest wie sie den
vulkan hier nennen nun schon aktiv er
hat einen langen atem
die evangelische kirche in deutschland
wählt in den nächsten tagen eine neue
führung begonnen hat die synodentagung
mit einem gottesdienst in bremen der
ratsvorsitzende heinrich bedford strohm
tritt nicht mehr zur wahl an er räumte
ein dass die evangelische kirche bei der
aufarbeitung von missbrauchsfällen noch
einen weiten weg vor sich habe
jetzt bist du dran mit der schwimm-em in
kasan da holt isabelle rose zum zweiten
mal bronze rund florian wellbrock
olympiasieger im freiwasserschwimmen hat
auf der 25 meter bahn auch nochmal
geglänzt nach gold über 1500 meter holt
sich der magdeburger auf der 800 meter
freistil strecke die silbermedaille über
die gesamte renndistanz kopf-an-kopf der
italiener premiere auf bahn 3 oben und
wellbrock darunter auf bahn 4 im ziel
trennen beide nur fünf
hundertstelsekunden gold gregorio
premiere in neuer europarekordzeit
silber florian wellbrock bronze-gewinn
sven schwarz aus hannover bereits in gut
einem monat treffen die rivalen
wellbrock und pall trainiere bei der wm
in abu dhabi wieder aufeinander
ebenfalls zu einer medaille schwimmt
isabelle rose die 19 jährige gewinnt
bronze über 200 meter freistil gold geht
an die russin kierpiec die koffer
eins zu eins endet das erste
sonntagsspiel in der fußball-bundesliga
robert andrich rettet bayer leverkusen
mit dem ausgleich in der neunzigsten
minute einen punkt bei hertha bsc
tag des handballs in deutschland die neu
formierte nationalmannschaft der männer
verliert dabei in düsseldorf den test
gegen portugal mit sieben neulingen
verspielt das team von bundestrainer
alfred gislason gegen den wm zehnte noch
einen vier-tore-vorsprung einer der
erfolgreichsten werfer johannes dollar
vier mal trifft der kapitän nachfolge
des heute offiziell verabschiedeten uwe
gensheimer
zum ersten mal hat eine aktuelle
marathon olympiasiegerin auch den
klassiker gewonnen perez jetzt hier ist
schnellste beim jubiläum in new york die
28 jahre alte kenianerin erreicht im
schlussspurt das ziel bei der
fünfzigsten ausgabe im big apple nach
zwei stunden 22 minuten und 39 sekunden
auch der mann mit dem höchsten
durchschnitt tempo kommt aus kenia
albert kurier braucht für die gut 42
kilometer 2 0 822
sehr flott
das wetter morgen bringt sonne nur
leider nicht für alle teils wechselnd
teils stark bewölkt im norden und osten
auch etwas regen im südwesten größere
sonnige abschnitte höchstwerte sechs bis
zwölf grad und auch in den nächsten
tagen hält sich diese mischung aus sonne
wolken und viel nebel das heute journal
um viertel vor zehn mit claus kleber wir
danken ihnen für ihr interesse wünschen
einen guten start in die neue woche und
empfehlen jetzt schalke unter labbadia
und berlin direkt